I'm just going to start with
congratulations on the movie
um a ton of questions for you uh the
first being that I I can't imagine what
it was like I read that you got to
listen to the original recordings of
Whitney and hear like the the vocal
tracks isolated hearing her breaths yes
so I'm just curious
yeah what is because most of us are
never going to hear that what was it
actually like listening to those tracks
and hearing her voice so alone and
hearing how incredible it was it's it's
like very intimate
um it's a very kind of uh
you feel like she's in the room like you
say something different to you know when
the music is going and you oh gosh
that's the hook I remember and there's
the trumpets over there it's just her it
feels like she's kind of just talking to
you in a way and also there's
yeah it was it was crazy
it was actually yeah I don't know it
felt it made me feel closer to her in a
way you could you could almost just
track back and be like oh my gosh this
like it's 82 and I'm I'm just on the
other side of the glass and she's just
seeing over there and she's gonna like
come through the door and just be like
how was that
I can't imagine
um the one of the things about this
movie is you have to portray Whitney at
different periods of her life and I know
the way filmmaking works and how
sometimes you have to film things
possibly on the same day or very close
to one another so did you ever have to
play her as a teenager and then much
older on the same day and what is that
like
um
there was a few of those days where like
and it can't be helped it just happens
to scheduling sometimes but yeah
uh play 19 and then probably like 35
midday and then hop over to like 42.
um I kind of knew that was going to
happen so I was trying to prepare myself
beforehand
um and I in terms of my the most
important thing you know because I know
that costume hat costume was sorted hair
and makeup they're amazing my job was to
make sure that um I had a different feel
for the different Decades of Whitney's
life
um vocally especially
um so I kind of went into my zone and
like had like on YouTube I've still got
on my phone where it's like different
three sections of Whitney's vocal tone
during her life and trying to pinpoint
um I would talk to my vocal coach who
was on set um Bridget Jackson and be
like are we one or two or three on this
one and she'd be like you're number two
so then I'd remember like what are the
notes for like very technical
um but it helped me stay as calm as I
possibly could on those busy days when
you were looking at the schedule of
filming I'm sure there was a day or two
that you had Circle like these are going
to be really tough days what were what
was on the schedule that what were those
days for you before filming began yeah
uh in terms of the acting scenes there
was like
um there was just things that I was
nervous about doing you know like some
of the more emotional scenes which you
just never know what your body's gonna
do on the day it's just I hope you're
like God I hope I can conjure up that
emotion
um in terms of performances there was
there is that sequence where we do about
four different songs on the same stage
um and it's meant to represent one of
her world tours and we did that in one
day
um and so we had to also it was trying
to track how exhausting a world tour is
so each performance had a different
feeling to it where she's getting more
and more tired so it was like a one day
in this in this um on in this kind of I
don't know Studio space where we went
through four songs four different looks
um and and four different uh
choreography movement acting stuff
it was a day it was a day my dude it was
a day but it was actually one of my
favorite days and it's actually one of
my favorite
um like sequences now
um I already have to go I'm just gonna
say I wish people I wish more people
knew how difficult it is sometimes
making a movie yeah yeah you know yeah
but that's not the magic too
very true Hey listen congrats and I hope
it's a huge hit for you thank you so
much I appreciate it have a great day